inga you said of several themes that I
find compelling one is about the
longevity of an institution like year
over time and you mentioned about how
the endowment allows yield to in some
ways operate without the pressures of a
particular political moment which
Berkeley and other state universities
have suffered or they can benefit
depending on a particular moment what at
the same time it has ongoing operational
issues that are affected is is there a a
balance that is reached that sometimes
are murky when I say that I talk about
say a time when I was here when we were
as an institution dealing with issues
that were being raised internationally
around apartheid and investments in
South Africa that that had a that were
taking people in many different
directions how how does a university a
great one like this deal with those
kinds of tensions between endowment for
long-term existence short-term Neil and
big global issues well a university
deals for these issues by having a
really good president I think you know
to strike that balance between what is
core what is crucial what should we
never give up is important and I think
it's also fairly easy obviously a great
university needs great faculty and it's
great students and so how do we how do
we maintain that and how do we continue
to enhance it and when you think of it
that way then you can think of a lot of
different ways of how you have to go
about it and philanthropy can can
they are all in it I think we have to be
careful about things that may be very
short term and you know so for example
one particular major is running up you
know everybody wants to be that and
there is this other major over here that
nobody wants so we could say oh if I
were a businessman I'll put more money
into this and I'll get rid of that but
you know things in science in humanity
so design they don't always work that
way and all of a sudden this goes down
again and this goes up in so you have to
have a sense of what kind of an
institution you want to be and maintain
those programs those values throughout
the you know the shifts thank you thank
you Inga Thank You students this has
been philanthropy in action I am Maxum
thorne Inga Reichenbach the vice
president of Yale University's
fundraising shared with us her passion
for higher education and what it takes
to make a great institution and how much
we depend on our donors and the
community to do what it takes to invest
in our community and in the world now
what are you going to do to change the
world